we're used to the idea of great works of
art being reproduced but how about great
bottles of wine science is helping to
replicate some of the world's most
popular vintages by closely studying
their flavor profiles in the lab and
then selling them at a reduced price
Barry Petersen has the story
wine is bottled poetry wrote Robert
Louis Stevenson but for this story
blendin a little Shakespeare who once
said what's in a name the name here is
replicas as in replicas of famous wines
made to taste the same but easier on the
wallet Harry Walker is the CEO of
integrated Everage group maker of
replica wines what would the replica
version of a $50 wine cost $20 wouldn't
I know it when I taste it
no you wouldn't know when you taste it
traditional winemaking begins with the
grapes but replica begins in this denver
laboratory here famous name wines they
want to replicate are analyzed down to
parts per billion overseen by Sean
Callen director of operations and
quality there are a lot of chemicals in
wine and they can tell us a lot of
different things and these chemicals
tell us things like what well yeah both
taste and aroma
so these chemicals your brain will tell
you smell a certain way or they taste a
certain way and we're able to map it out
and say this wine is this buttery this
oaky has notes of green apples in it has
a certain amount of dryness to it the
heat from the amount of alcohol Callen
and his team create a chemical map of
the distinctive flavors and aromas then
replicas mixes its grapes to match the
analysis and has their chief wine
officer master sommelier Brent Zimmerman
check out the result the old-fashioned
way by tasting it so you're not involved
in the chemistry you're involved in
assessing III finalized the flavor
profile make sure I mean if we're
analyzing stuff in a lab and the
winemaking team is is is really close
and they say hey we've got three or four
different blends that we think are
really really close I'm the final say as
to you know does the wine
a scream Zimmerman invited me for a
blind taste test which was the replica
which was the original it was a wine
talk moment so in terms of the real
versus the replica would it have all of
those things you just described the
tannin taste the dry taste the taste of
flowers and fruit and things like that
both of these wines have all of those
elements yes with my less developed
palette I could tell one wine was
different from the other but I wrongly
picked the replica as the original what
I can tell you is we've spoken with
thousands of consumers around the
country about our wines and the reaction
is just overwhelmingly positive the
truth is in the tasting so to find out
we invited some friends and neighbors to
our home here in Denver Colorado to tell
us if they like the replica or the real
we matched the original to its replica
counterpart using our costs for the real
wine and replicas suggested prices for
theirs the first Chardonnay Far Niente
versus the replica called
/ simper our tasters tally 5 for the
real only two four replicas which one do
you like I like the real one the replica
doesn't have much taste Rombauer
Chardonnay against replicas retrofit 6
prefers the real only one the replica
the Rombauer I thought was about better
we went down a lot smoother in the
replica then Mayo me Pinot Noir and
replicas misbehaved a clear victory for
replicas winning fortitude with one time
finally the prisoner against replicas
pickpocket 6 to 1 for the real thing
the replica just didn't match up
didn't come all together for me but some
of our tasters said they would still buy
the replica because it cost less that's
the point says sommelier Zimmerman so
you're not really aiming to make the
rolls-royce of wines you're really much
more in like the Subaru Ford of wines
that most of us would buy and take home
at night for our friends yeah it's a
perfect analogy a Roman author once
wrote in wine there is truth but it's
wine buyers we will finally decide if
truth really can be half and half the
price for CBS this morning Saturday
Barry Petersen Denver Barry didn't fool
me that was a ticket to a party I am so
torn by this I love wine and I love the
idea that you could find something
cheaper but knowing two of those wines
really well I find it hard to believe
that I would take the cheaper over that
taste because they know that taste so
well he did a blind taste yet exactly it
seemed tainted hey it's cheaper though
that could work what are you gonna do
hello